rejoignez-moi sur patronne pour accéder
à l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas créole
le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de
est un philosophe allemand né en 1889 il
est l'auteur d'un ouvrage qui a
bouleversé la philosophie occidentale
contemporaine être étant publié en 1927
un ouvrage difficile très technique très
pointu c'est quelqu'un qui a eu une
énorme influence sur la postérité que ce
soit sur Sartre sur Merleau-Ponty ou sur
Levinas mais c'est aussi quelqu'un qui a
été membre du Parti national socialiste
de 1933 à 1944 et si je le précise
d'entrée de jeu c'est parce que pour
certains une fois qu'on a dit ça on a
tout dit
un philosophe qui adhère aux idées du
régime nazi c'est un philosophe qui
n'aurait par la même aucune crédibilité
c'est un point de vue mais on peut aussi
considérer qu'une fois qu'on a dit ça on
n'a pas tout dit que si Deger a autant
marqué les esprits c'est qu'il y a des
raisons des raisons proprement
philosophiques et que son œuvre mérite
qu'on s'y banche non seulement parce
qu'elle a eu une grande influence et
qu'il faut comprendre pourquoi elle a eu
autant d'influence mais aussi parce que
résumer la valeur d'une œuvre
philosophique aux égarements personnels
de son auteur c'est un peu court
Sartre a soutenu l'URSS pendant la
période d'egoulag alors même que sa
philosophie prenait la liberté John
Locke a pris part au commerce des
esclaves tout en soutenant les droits de
l'homme et je ne parle même pas de
Rousseau qui a abandonné ses enfants à
l'Assistance publique avant d'écrire un
traité sur l'éducation on peut y voir
une incohérence entre la vie et l'oeuvre
ça n'enlève rien à la pertinence de
l'oeuvre or c'est sur son œuvre qu'on
juge un philosophe
et donc si on peut reprocher à Heidegger
ses opinions politiques ce qui va nous
intéresser aujourd'hui c'est son œuvre
ce préambule est en fait et vous n'êtes
évidemment pas obligé d'y adhérer on
doit maintenant se pencher sur cette
question qu'est-ce que Heidegger a
apporté de six considérables à la
philosophie et bien il a apporté une
révélation et c'est volontairement que
j'emploie le révélation parce qu'en grec
révélation c'est à l'ethia le
dévoilement le découvrement
raidger a dévoilé quelque chose il a
dévoilé le fait qu'en 2500 ans
d'histoire de la philosophie il y a une
question à laquelle est philosophe n'ont
jamais répondu
une question à laquelle ils n'ont jamais
répondu alors même que c'est la question
la plus importante et la plus
fondamentale que jamais eu à traiter la
philosophie cette question c'est la
question de l'être
ce que nous dire et de guerre c'est que
ça fait 2500 ans que les philosophes
nous parlent de l'être mais qui n'ont
jamais pris le temps de dire ce qui
était l'être ils n'ont jamais pris le
temps de le définir
ils ont fait comme si tout le monde
savait ce que c'était comme si c'était
une évidence
ils ont construit tout un édifice ils
ont construit tout un monument
conceptuel sur cette évidence
et ce faisant ils ont recouvert la
question de l'être
ils ont empilé sur elle tout un tas de
théories au point nous faire oublier que
sous cette annoncement de théorie il y a
quelque chose qui n'a toujours pas été
explicité en résumé skyde de Girl a
révélé c'est que toute l'histoire de la
métaphysique était bâtie sur du sable
et qu'il fallait reprendre les choses à
la base en proposant une analyse et une
élucidation de la question de l'être
alors là on pourrait déjà faire
remarquer que ce que dit de guerre bah
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai au sens où
il y a des philosophes qui ont étudié
l'être sa porte main non ça s'appelle
l'ontologie on Tosse lettre logos le
discours
l'anthologie c'est l'étude de l'être
quand Platon propose sa théorie des
essences il parle de l'être
quand Aristote écrit son traités des
catégories il parle bien de l'être et
quand Descartes dit je pense donc je
suis il parle bien lui aussi de l'être
nous dit que les philosophes ont
délaissé la question de l'être est-ce
qu'il serait pas un peu en train de se
moquer de nous est-ce qu'il serait pas
en train d'inventer un problème là où il
y en a pas
et ben non il a raison
il a raison et tout ce que j'ai dit
jusqu'à présent on vous parlant de
Platon en vous parlant d'Aristote ou de
Descartes c'est en réalité la preuve non
pas que Heidegger se trompe mais au
contraire qu'il a raison
pourquoi parce que tout ce que je viens
de dire montre que les philosophes ne se
sont pas intéressés à l'être ils se sont
intéressés aux choses qui sont
ils ne se sont pas intéressés à l'être
ils se sont intéressés aux êtres à ce
qu'on appelle les étangs à NT
autrement dit l'histoire de la
philosophie s'est construite sur une
confusion une sorte de malentendu
originel qui est la confusion entre
l'être et l'étang
et pour vous le faire comprendre je vais
faire une analogie
imaginez que vous vouliez savoir ce
qu'est la vie donc vous demandez à
quelqu'un de vous expliquer ce qu'est la
vie et là la personne revient avec un
animal et elle vous dit voilà la vie
à ce moment là qu'est-ce que vous allez
lui dire vous allez lui dire bah non
c'est pas la vie ça c'est quelque chose
qui possède la vie
ce n'est pas la vie c'est un vivant
et là la personne va dire ok je reviens
et elle revient avec une fleur bon du
coup c'est un peu bancal parce qu'une
fleur coupée c'est une fleur qui n'est
plus en vie mais bon vous avez compris
l'idée donc la personne revient avec une
fleur et elle vous dit voilà la vie
et là vous lui dites non toujours pas
c'est toujours pas ça la vie
encore une fois c'est quelque chose qui
possède la vie qui contient la vie mais
la vie en elle-même la vie en tant que
vie c'est quelque chose qui est au-delà
des êtres vivants et donc tu auras beau
montrer toutes les choses qui vivent tu
auras beau montrer toute une collection
d'être vivant tu n'auras toujours pas
expliqué ce qui était la vie
et bien c'est exactement ça que nous dit
heyder ce qu'il nous dit c'est que de la
même façon que la vie ne se résume pas
au vivant l'être ne se résume pas à
laiton
or les philosophes les métaphysiciens se
sont concentrés sur les étangs ils les
ont décrits ils les ont analysés ils les
ont classé et ils ont fait comme s'ils
parlaient de l'être
si bien que maintenant si on pose la
question un philosophe qu'est-ce que
l'être il va nous répondre
tout le monde sait bien ce qu'est l'être
on n'a pas besoin de définir puisque ça
fait 2500 ans qu'on en parle ce que nous
dit c'est que ça fait 2500 ans qu'on
parle de quelque chose qui n'est pas
l'être ça fait 2500 ans qu'on présuppose
l'être
et qu'on fait comme si on l'avait défini
et donc ce qu'on va faire avec
une exploration de cette question de
l'être pour tenter de comprendre ce qui
se cache réellement derrière ce terme
quand on se penche sur le verbe être en
français on s'aperçoit que c'est un
verbe polysémique et qu'on peut le
mettre à peu près à toutes les sauces
comme le verbe faire vous savez on fait
la cuisine on fait attention on fait la
queue faire c'est le verbe interdit dans
les rédactions au collège parce qu'il
n'y a pas de verbe plus imprécis bon
pour dire que le verbe être c'est un peu
la même chose on est triste on est
français on est en retard
et on voit bien traverser exemple que le
verbe être est un verbe très flou
puisqu'il peut exprimer à la fois un
état émotionnel une nationalité ou une
situation ponctuelle donc finalement
dire être ce n'est pas dire grand chose
tant qu'on a pas dit en quel sens on
parle d'être
autrement dit dès qu'on se penche sur la
question de l'être on s'aperçoit qu'il
existe plusieurs manières d'être
plusieurs modes d'être
bien ce que nous dire c'est que les
philosophes depuis l'Antiquité n'ont
jamais pris la peine de distinguer les
différents modes d'être ils ont pris le
mot être dans un sens unique et donc
dans un sens forcément réducteur et dans
quel sens est-ce qu'ils l'ont pris ils
l'ont pris dans le sens de la
subsistance
dire qu'une chose est c'est dire qu'elle
subsiste
donc on dira par exemple que ce micro
est au sens où il subsiste devant moi
et là j'imagine que certains d'entre
vous ont un autre verbe qui leur vient à
l'esprit le verbe exister
dire qu'une chose est ce serait tout
simplement dire qu'elle existe
alors oui mais non
oui parce qu'effectivement au sens où
l'emploi couramment le verbe existait
ferait très bien l'affaire existait
c'est avoir une réalité on est d'accord
mais non parce que chat et de guerre le
verbe exister à une signification très
précise
et la signification que Heidegger donne
au mot existence et très différente et
on verra tout à l'heure de ce qu'il
appelle la subsistance
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire qu'une
chose est au sens où elle subsiste
ça veut tout simplement dire qu'elle
occupe une place dans le monde donc vous
qui m'écoutez vous êtes vous subsistez
au sens où vous occuper un certain
espace
votre corps
occupe un certain espace
si bien que si je me déplace dans la
pièce où vous vous trouvez sans voir que
vous vous y trouvez je risque de vous
entrer dedans
votre corps va faire obstacle au mien
c'est ça la subsistance
l'occupation d'un espace
sauf que ça pourrait Deger c'est pas
convaincant c'est pas convaincant parce
qu'autant on peut dire d'une chose
qu'elle subsiste quelle occupe un
certain espace autant parler de
subsistance pour l'être humain c'est
réducteur
si vous préférez l'être humain n'est pas
dans le monde comme l'arbre est dans le
jardin
la manière d'être de l'être humain n'est
pas la même que celle d'un objet inerte
ou d'un étang naturel
en clair être ne veut pas dire la même
chose selon qu'on parle d'une personne
ou d'un objet
et ça on peut le comprendre en 30
secondes
que dit-on à propos d'une personne qui
est morte
on dit qu'elle n'est plus
mourir c'est ne plus être mais pourtant
quand une personne meurt son corps est
toujours là
il subsiste toujours alors oui il va se
décomposer avec le temps ça d'accord
mais physiquement parlant la personne
qui meurt est toujours
bien justement si on dit de quelqu'un
qui vient de mourir qu'il n'est plus
c'est justement parce que pour une
personne être ne signifie pas uniquement
occuper un espace
être ne signifie pas uniquement reposer
et justement que dit-on d'une personne
qui est morte et enterrée
qu'elle repose ici
on repose quand on est plus
reposer c'est être pour une chose mais
ce n'est pas être pour un être humain
alors évidemment on va approfondir on va
expliquer en quoi pour Heidegger lettre
de l'être humain n'est pas comparable
avec lettre de la chose parce qu'en
réalité c'est ça le cœur de son propos
mais avant ça on va devoir faire un
détour parce qu'avant de parler de
l'être humain il faut déjà préciser en
quel sens il y a être chez les objets
or pourrait Deger il y a deux types
d'objets
au sens où un objet peut avoir de
manière d'être différente
il peut être de façon indépendante et il
peut être de façon relationnelle
et c'est là qu'il faut introduire une
notion extrêmement importante une notion
sur laquelle on ne peut pas comprendre
ce que veut dire Heidegger qui est la
phénoménologie alors on va pas rentrer
dans le détail la seule chose que je
vais vous demander de retenir c'est que
avoir une approche phénoménologique des
choses c'est envisager les choses non
pas comme indépendante de nous non pas
comme séparé de nous mais au travers de
la relation que nous avons avec elle
la phénoménologie c'est étudier non pas
la manière dont les choses sont mais la
manière dont elle nous apparaissent
parce que pour Heidegger la façon dont
les choses nous apparaissent fait aussi
partie de leur être
je prendre un exemple si vous écoutez
une chanson disons votre chanson
préférée vous n'allez pas vous dire
j'écoute une succession de notes vous
n'allez pas parler de cette chanson de
manière purement technique et pour ainsi
dire indépendante de vous vous allez
parler de ce que cette chanson produit
en vous les émotions qu'elle éveillent
en vous des images qu'elle crée en vous
c'est le principe de toute œuvre d'art
quand on parle d'une oeuvre d'art on en
parle pas comme d'une entité
indépendante de nous on parle en même
temps de ce qu'elle vient toucher dans
notre sensibilité
donc on parle de la relation qu'on a
avec elle si on voulait parler d'une
œuvre d'art indépendamment de notre
interaction avec cette œuvre d'art ça
n'aurait aucun sens
bien ce que le diable de guerre c'est
qu'il faut faire comme ça avec tout
avec tous les objets qui sont autour de
nous
parce que la manière dont on se rapporte
à un objet définit l'être de cet objet
pour nous
autrement dit l'être d'un objet c'est
toujours lettre pour nous de cet objet
avoir une approche phénoménologique
c'est inclure dans notre analyse d'une
chose notre rapport à cette chose
et c'est ça pour aldeger qui fait défaut
dans l'analyse traditionnelle de l'être
le fait de considérer l'être des choses
comme séparées de nous alors que dans
les faits dans notre expérience concrète
des choses il y a toujours une relation
entre nous et la chose qu'on examine
puisque la chose qu'on examine on est en
train de l'examiner et en examine pas
une chose séparément notre examen
il faut intégrer l'examiner dans
l'examen il faut intégrer notre rapport
à la chose dans l'analyse de la chose
c'est ça la phénoménologie
et pour vous prouver qu'on fait tous de
la phénoménologie là encore je vais
prendre un exemple
imaginez que c'est votre première
journée de travail et que vous
rencontrez votre patron votre patron ou
votre patronne ça marche pour les deux
sexes
bien le jour où vous rencontrez votre
patron vous ne rencontrez pas
Jean-Michel lambda 40 ans célibataire
vous rencontrez votre patron
quand vous parlez de lui à vos amis vous
parlez de lui en disant mon patron
quand vous parlez avec lui à la machine
à café vous parlez avec votre patron
autrement dit l'être de cette personne
va se confondre avec ce qu'elle est par
rapport à vous on pourrait dire avec ce
qu'elle représente pour vous
tout ce que vous direz sur elle tout ce
que vous penserez sur elle sera
conditionné prédéterminé par le fait que
c'est votre patron et vous aurez beau
croire que vous parlez de lettres d'une
personne d'une personne séparée et
indépendante de vous la réalité c'est
que l'être de cette personne sera
inséparable de la relation que vous avez
avec elle
son être saura indissociable de son être
pour vous
et c'est pour ça que le jour où
Jean-Michel lambda va vous inviter à
dîner si vous acceptez vous ne pourrez
pas ignorer la petite voix dans votre
tête qui vous dira je suis invité à
dîner par mon patron avec ce que ça
implique de Gênes d'hésitation et
d'excitation que vous n'auriez pas
éprouvé si vous aviez été invité par
quelqu'un qui n'est rien pour vous
et peut-être qu'à l'issue de la soirée
votre patron sera devenu pour vous
Jean-Michel
voir Jean-Mi
conclusion lettre est toujours devancée
par notre expérience de l'être
parler de l'être c'est commencer par
parler de l'être pour nous
considérer qu'on pourrait parler des
choses en soi c'est-à-dire
indépendamment de notre relation à elle
parlez des choses comme uniquement
subsistantes comme objectif c'est-à-dire
comme de pure objets dont nous serions
déconnectés c'est ça pour Heidegger
l'erreur fondamentale des philosophes et
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont passés
complètement à côté de la question de
l'être
prenons Aristote
aristote a tenté de classer les êtres il
a tenté de classer les étangs ça veut
être tout à fait précis et les a classés
selon 10 catégories selon la quantité
selon la qualité selon la position selon
l'état et d'autres encore
et l'être de la chose c'est la synthèse
de ces catégories
la synthèse de ces attributs
donc si on prend l'exemple d'un bureau
un bureau pourrait être plus ou moins
long plus ou moins large c'est sa
quantité il pourrait être blanc ou noir
en bois massif ou en bois aggloméré
c'est sa qualité il pourra être face à
la fenêtre ou face à la porte c'est sa
position il pourra être neuf ou abîmé
c'est son état etc etc
donc c'est ça les catégories d'Aristote
une classification des caractéristiques
de la chose et la première catégorie
Aristote c'est la substance
substance qui au passage a donné
subsistance
alors attention
substances en philosophie ça ne veut pas
dire produit chimique ça ne veut même
pas dire matière
substance ça veut dire ce qui reste
quand on a dépouillé la chose de ses
caractéristiques non essentielles
substance ces substrat ce qui se tient
en dessous en dessous de quoi en dessous
des caractéristiques
donc pour reprendre mon exemple du
bureau si je modifie les dimensions de
mon bureau si je lui ajoute une
extension ou au contraire si je
raccourcis son plateau ça reste quand
même un bureau
la substance bureau demeure
si je repeins mon bureau autrement dit
si je modifie sa qualité ça reste encore
un bureau
ça s'apporte un nom en philosophie ça
s'appelle la variation
idétique une expression compliquée pour
dire quelque chose de très simple
puisque la variation est d'éthique c'est
simplement le fait d'imaginer tout ce
qu'on pourrait faire varier dans l'objet
sans que cela n'altère la nature de
l'objet sans que cela n'altère son
essence et ce qu'on ne peut pas modifier
dans l'objet sans modifier la nature de
l'objet sans la faire disparaître pour
ainsi dire ça fait partie de son essence
dans le cas du bureau si on lui retire
son plateau ça ne peut plus être un
bureau
le plateau fait partie de l'essence du
bureau ce n'est pas un attribut
secondaire c'est un attribut essentiel
d'ailleurs c'est amusant parce qu'à
l'origine bureau c'était le nom qu'on
donnait au tapis qu'on mettait sur le
bureau pour le protéger de l'encre cet
équivalent du sous-main donc d'une
certaine manière on peut retirer le
bureau sans faire disparaître le bureau
mais blague à part ce qu'il faut retenir
ici c'est que durant des siècles et des
siècles on a fonctionné avec cette
conception de lettres c'est à dire avec
une conception de lettres comme
subsistance la chose était séparée de
nous elle était à distance de nous et on
analysait son être sur un mode qui se
voulait neutre et objectif
bien ça pour Heidegger ça va pas
ça va pas parce que dans notre
expérience quotidienne dans notre
rapport concret aux choses ce n'est pas
comme ça que les choses nous
apparaissent
et si ce n'est pas comme ça que les
choses nous apparaissent ça veut dire
qu'on passe à côté d'une dimension
essentielle de leur être
ce que veut dire Hegger c'est que nous
sommes toujours en interaction avec les
choses
on envisage pas les choses autour de
nous comme de simples entités posées
dans le monde en tout cas pas de prime
abord de prime abord on envisage les
choses par rapport à nous par rapport à
ce qu'on pourrait en faire ou par
rapport à ce qu'elle représente pour
nous à leur fonction ou à leur
signification
mais pas à leur être objectif
on envisage pas notre bureau en se
disant quelles sont ces catégories on
l'envisage en se disant il est pratique
ce bureau il est grand ça me fait de la
place pour travailler
il est beau tout en bois massif il va
bien avec ma bibliothèque
il est bien positionné face à la fenêtre
j'ai une bonne lumière pour travailler
autrement dit et c'est ça l'idée
fondamentale de Heidegger lettre de
laiton c'est la nature de la relation
que nous avons avec cet étang et la
plupart des étangs qui nous envirent ce
sont des étangs que nous utilisons
ce sont des étangs qui ont une fonction
pour nous
et c'est pour ça que Heidegger appelle
ses étangs des outils
et lettre de l'outil ce n'est pas la
subsistance
autrement dit ce n'est pas simplement le
fait d'être posé devant nous
l'être de l'outil c'est l'usage qu'on en
fait lettre de l'outil c'est d'être
disponible pour son utilisation
pour Heidegger un objet peut donc avoir
deux modes d'être la subsistance qui est
le seul mode d'être que les philosophes
ont perçus sans vraiment le percevoir
d'ailleurs puisque pour eux ce n'était
pas un modèle c'était l'être tout entier
donc la subsistance premier mode d'être
deuxième mode d'être la disponibilité
appelle lettre à portée de main
et ce que l'analyse de Heidegger va
révéler c'est que la plupart du temps
les objets autour de nous ne nous
apparaissent pas comme subsistant mais
comme disponible
il ne nous apparaissent pas comme des
choses mais comme des outils
alors j'ai bien conscience que ce qu'on
dit depuis tout à l'heure n'est pas du
tout évident que c'est même assez
compliqué
c'est compliqué dans la forme mais dans
le fond vous allez voir que c'est
beaucoup plus intuitif donc ce que je
vous propose c'est de faire une petite
pause détente pour pouvoir repartir du
bon pied
je vais vous demander de fermer les yeux
et d'imaginer un outil un outil de
bricolage
est-ce que vous l'avez
je prédis que vous avez choisi un
marteau bon c'était peut-être un
tournevis mais on va prendre l'exemple
du marteau
un marteau c'est un objet que vous allez
utiliser pour planter des clous ou pour
casser une vitre ou pour menacer
quelqu'un peu importe dans tous les cas
ce marteau il est prévu pour être
utilisé
outils utiles c'est le même mot et
utiliser ça veut dire
rediriger vers quelque chose d'autre que
lui si vous préférez l'outil n'a pas
vraiment d'être indépendamment de ce à
quoi il sert puisque sa raison d'être
c'est précisément de servir à quelque
chose
alors que si on prend par exemple un
rocher ou un arbre ces choses n'ont pas
à proprement parler de fonctions elles
sont là elles occupent une place dans le
monde mais vous n'allez pas les utiliser
ou plutôt si vous pouvez les utiliser
vous pouvez utiliser le rocher pour vous
asseoir vous pouvez utiliser l'ombre de
l'arbre pour faire une sieste mais dans
ce cas là ce que vous faites c'est que
vous transformez une chose en un outil
vous modifiez son mode d'être
vous les faites sortir de leur
subsistance et vous les intégrez dans le
réseau des outils
childer un outil c'est donc un objet qui
s'inscrit dans un réseau d'objets
c'est pas simplement un outil de
bricolage
un outil c'est tout objet en tant qu'il
se rapporte à vous et en tant qu'il se
rapporte à d'autres objets
donc ce que dit de guerre c'est que
l'ensemble objet se divise en deux
catégories les choses qui existent pour
ainsi dire indépendamment de nous
indépendamment de notre rapport à elle
et les outils qui sont interconnectés
les uns aux autres à travers l'usage
qu'on en fait
le mode d'être de la chose on l'a dit
tout à l'heure c'est la subsistance
le fait de reposer dans le monde
indépendamment de nous le mode d'être de
l'outil c'est la disponibilité
certaines traductions proposent la
maniabilité c'est-à-dire le fait tout
simplement que ces objets ont une
fonction pour nous
prenons un exemple si vous vous promenez
dans un parc et que vous tombez sur une
nappe posée sur l'herbe vous n'allez pas
vous dire la nappe est venue toute seule
non elle est là parce qu'elle a été mise
là par des gens qui l'ont utilisé
si bien que si vous voyez une nappe dans
un parc votre premier réflexe ça va être
de chercher des personnes à qui elle
appartient qui l'a laissé là
donc l'objet va vous renvoyer vers le
propriétaire de l'objet ou vers son
utilisateur
donc si on reprend le vocabulaire de
Heidegger quand vous voyez une nappe
vous ne voyez pas une chose vous voyez
un outil
vous ne voyez pas quelque chose qui
subsiste de manière indépendante vous
voyez quelque chose qui fait partie d'un
réseau d'usage et de signification
un pique-nique
vous allez vous dire que sur cette nappe
il y a probablement des miettes de pain
du pain qui aura été coupé avec un
couteau
vous ne serez pas étonné si sur cette
nappe vous trouvez des assiettes des
gobelets des serviettes en papier bref à
travers la nappe l'outil nappe vous
allez voir apparaître un monde d'objets
interconnecté
et ce monde d'objets interconnecté c'est
squiders appelle un monde ambiant
votre salon c'est votre monde ambiant
parce que c'est le monde formé par des
objets qui se renvoient les uns aux
autres et qui servent à votre usage
quotidien
le canapé renvoie à la télécommande qui
renvoie à la télévision qui renvoie à la
box internet qui renvoie à vous
votre cuisine c'est votre monde ambiance
frigo four
ustensile et vous au milieu
c'est ça un monde ambiant ce n'est pas
le monde au sens objectif du terme c'est
le monde dans lequel vous êtes engagé au
quotidien et qui fait qu'à proprement
parler nous ne vivons pas dans le même
monde
vous ne vivez pas dans mon monde de la
même façon que je ne vis pas dans votre
monde
si vous allez chez des gens pour la
première fois leur salon vous n'allez
pas l'envisager comme vous envisagez
votre salon
il n'aura pas la familiarité de votre
salon
ce n'est pas votre monde ambiant
vous n'allez pas y voir des outils vous
allez y voir des choses
des choses subsistantes
pas des choses disponibles
parce qu'on a le monde ambiant de ces
usages quotidiens de ces habitudes
quotidiennes
l'outil c'est l'objet familier qui parce
qu'il vous est familier ne retient même
plus votre attention
c'est l'objet incorporé dans vos usages
qui se font dans vos usages
au point de devenir invisible pour vous
c'est presque une extension de vous-même
vous l'utilisez comme ça en passant
négligemment
alors que l'outil du voisin sa
télécommande son canapé vous allez en
avoir un usage beaucoup plus respectueux
vous quand vous utilisez votre
télécommande vous l'attrapez sans
mammifère attention vous appuyez dessus
et vous la secouez si elle marche pas
alors que la télécommande du voisin si
vous devez l'utiliser vous allez faire
attention vous allez bien regarder là où
il faut appuyer avec un peu d'hésitation
et vous allez la reposer délicatement
sur la table basse
alors que fondamentalement ça reste
juste une télécommande
ben non c'est pas juste une télécommande
c'est une télécommande qui ne fait pas
partie de votre monde ambiant
elle fait partie d'un autre monde
ambiant
la télécommande du voisin elle n'est pas
disponible comme la vôtre
elle subsiste
remarquez comme nous sommes très
attentifs et très observateurs quand
nous allons dans un endroit qui nous est
pas familier c'est d'ailleurs comme ça
qu'on reconnaît un touriste il regarde
partout autour de lui comme si tout
était intéressant
le touriste n'est pas familier avec le
monde qui visite parce que ce n'est pas
son monde ambiance et ça ça va
structurer son rapport à ce qui est
autour de lui il va être beaucoup plus
concentré beaucoup plus contemplatif
l'habitant lui n'a pas le temps d'être
contemplatif
il est dans l'usage il est dans la
familiarité du monde ambiant
résumons ce que dit en trois points
premier point la philosophie occidentale
depuis l'Antiquité n'envisager qu'un
seul mode d'être de l'étang l'être comme
subsistance
et elle a fait de la subsistance la
seule manière d'être possible de les
temps
deuxième point
Heidegger propose d'intégrer une
approche phénoménologique de la question
de l'être en partant non pas de l'être
objectif mais de son être pour nous
et la conclusion de son analyse c'est
que le premier mode d'être de l'étang ce
n'est pas la subsistance mais la
disponibilité
troisième point pour Heidegger il ne
s'agit pas de nier la subsistance de
l'objet il s'agit de comprendre que la
subsistance n'est que le second mode
d'être de l'objet
second au sens où ce n'est pas celui que
nous rencontrons de prime abord car le
premier mode d'être sous lequel l'objet
se présente à nous c'est la
disponibilité
l'être n'ont pas comme chose mais comme
outil
il faut ajouter à ce troisième point une
précision c'est que l'outil n'est pas
condamné à rester outil
de même que la chose n'est pas condamnée
à rester chose ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que le mode d'être de l'objet
dépend d'abord de ce que vous en faites
ou de ce que vous pouvez en faire
on a pris l'exemple tout à l'heure du
rocher sur lequel on peut s'asseoir ou
de l'arbre dont on peut profiter de
l'ombre de prime abord un rocher ou un
arbre ne sont pas des outils
ce sont des choses
car ils ne font pas partie d'un réseau
d'objets ayant pour nous un usage
ils sont là ils subsistent mais ne
servent pas en revanche si tout à coup
je décide d'utiliser le rocher pour
m'asseoir ou l'arbre pour faire une
sieste je rapatrise ces choses dans le
monde des outils
puisque je leur donne une fonction
et de la même façon que la chose peut se
révéler outils l'outil peut se révéler
chose
c'est ce qui se produit quand l'outil
perd sa fonction quand il se casse ou
quand il défaille je suis en train
d'écrire avec mon stylo tout va bien et
d'un coup mon stylo n'écrit plus il n'a
plus d'encre
substantialement parlant c'est toujours
un stylo mais relationnellement parlant
ce n'est plus un stylo car il perd ce
qui en fait un stylo à mes yeux sa
capacité à écrire
le stylo qui ne marche plus cesse d'être
un outil il devient une chose
mon stylo est alors bon pour la poubelle
la poubelle étant l'outil dont la
fonction est de recueillir les outils
morts
l'outil dont la fonction est de
recueillir les choses
ce qui veut dire une chose très
importante
c'est que l'être comme chose ou l'être
comme outil ne réside pas dans l'objet
il réside dans le rapport à l'objet
la distinction que faille de guerre ce
n'est pas une distinction entre étant
naturel et étant artificiel
alors oui bien sûr un étang artificiel a
de grandes chances d'être un outil au
sens où il est conçu comme un outil
mais ce n'est pas pour autant que nous
allons l'envisager sous le mode d'être
de l'outil
de la même façon qu'un étant naturel ne
sera pas nécessairement envisagé sous le
mode de la chose
c'est la relation à l'étang qui définit
l'être de l'étang
et c'est maintenant qu'on doit aborder
la question centrale la question
centrale c'est celle de l'être humain
parce que finalement tout ce qu'on a dit
jusqu'à présent c'est que l'être de
l'objet se définit par son rapport à
l'être humain
l'être de l'objet n'est pas inhérent à
l'objet lui-même
l'être de l'objet est inhérent à la
manière dont nous nous ira portons
mais du coup qui est ce nous capable de
déterminer l'être des objets qui est ce
nous que la tradition philosophique a
rangé parmi les étangs en général sans
voir qu'il était un étang tout à fait
particulier
en d'autres termes la question qu'il va
falloir aborder maintenant c'est que
veut dire être pour nous être humain
pour Heidegger l'être humain n'est pas
un état comme les autres
c'est même un étang radicalement
différent des autres étangs
et sa différence tient en fait que
l'être humain c'est un étang qui
s'interroge sur l'être
en clair lettres de l'être humain c'est
de se poser la question de l'être
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que l'être
humain se pose la question de l'être
ça veut dire tout simplement que l'être
humain est un être conscient
contrairement aux objets inanimés ou aux
étangs naturels
et donc si l'être humain est un être
conscient ça veut dire qu'il a la
capacité de se questionner le
questionner fait partie de l'être de
l'être humain
et donc si le questionnaire fait partie
de l'être de l'être humain ça veut dire
qu'on ne peut en aucun cas résumer son
être à sa substantialité
à sa corporéité pour employer un mot
pompeux
alors là on pourrait dire ok mais ça
Descartes l'avaient déjà dit des cartes
avaient dit que l'être de l'être humain
c'était la pensée le je pense du
Discours de la méthode oui mais sauf que
des cartes a raté quelque chose il a
raté le fait que la conscience de l'être
humain c'est précisément ce qui fait qui
n'a pas de sens
l'essence de l'être humain c'est que sa
conscience le rend indéfinissable
pour ceux qui ont écouté mes épisodes
sur Sartre vous savez que pour Sartre
l'homme n'a pas d'essence puisque son
essence c'est la liberté
autrement dit c'est sa capacité à
construire son essence à travers ses
choix la conscience c'est ce qui fait
que vous pouvez à tout moment cesser
d'être ce que vous étiez et devenir
quelqu'un d'autre
c'est ce qui fait que le garçon de café
peut rendre son tablier et ne plus être
garçon de café ne plus jouer son rôle de
garçon de café
la conscience c'est ce qui fait que vous
n'êtes pas enfermé dans une essence
comme le bureau est enfermé dans son
essence de bureau donc l'erreur de
Descartes c'est d'avoir figé lettre de
l'homme dans la conscience
c'est d'avoir
substantialiser la conscience
d'ailleurs il a fait de manière tout à
fait explicite en disant l'homme est une
substance pensante reste coquille danse
mais ce qu'on a pas vu des cartes c'est
que si la conscience est effectivement
ce qui définit l'être de l'homme elle
est en même temps ce qui fait que
l'homme n'est pas figé dans son être
la conscience rend l'homme capable de
réinventer en permanence son essence
pour Heidegger l'homme n'est pas une
substance pensante parce qu'il n'est pas
une substance tout court
lettre de l'homme c'est l'arrachement
permanent à soi
c'est la sortie permanente hors de soi
c'est la projection
l'homme est essentiellement projection
il se projette dans le temps d'où le
titre du livre de Heidegger être étant
pour indiquer que c'est sain le propre
de l'être humain la projection dans le
temps il se projette comme possibilité
comme possibilité d'action comme
possibilité de réalisation et comme
possibilité de disparition
et c'est ce qui fait que pour Heidegger
lettre de l'être humain c'est le pouvoir
être
c'est le possible
comme le dit Marlène zarader l'être
humain c'est ce qui a à être
c'est ce qui est constamment engagé dans
le processus de réalisation de son être
la chose elle ne peut pas être autre
chose que ce qu'elle est
l'être humain lui le peut raison pour
laquelle pour rail de guerre si l'être
de la chose c'est la subsistance l'être
de l'être humain c'est l'existence
vous comprenez maintenant je pense
pourquoi j'ai dit tout à l'heure qu'on
ne pouvait pas utiliser le mot existence
pour qualifier l'intro d'une chose
justement parce que pour Heidegger
l'existence c'est un concept qui
s'applique spécifiquement à l'être
humain parce qu'il appelle le dasaï ne
vous laissez pas intimider par le mot il
y a plusieurs traductions possibles au
mot design mais aujourd'hui on va
l'utiliser comme synonyme d'être humain
donc le design c'est ce qui ne se
contente pas de subsister c'est ce qui
existe
exister c'est être pour un être dont
l'être et là possibilité
et d'ailleurs Heidegger écrit existence
ek
existence comme il écrit extase ecstase
parce que ek en allemand ça traduit
l'idée de sortie
d'arrachement à
existé c'est s'arracher à l'être c'est
sortir en permanence de son être
c'est se projeter
on se projette dans le futur on
s'imagine quand on aura fait telle ou
telle chose
on se projette dans ce qu'on voudrait
devenir
l'évolution de notre vie de notre
carrière
on se projette quand on sera vieux
l'être du dazeigne ses lettres en avant
de soi
ces lettres qui sont ici lui-même
et qui de ce fait n'est jamais en repos
voilà pourquoi une dimension
fondamentale de notre être selon
Heidegger c'est ce qu'il appelle le
souci le souci ce n'est pas seulement
l'inquiétude le souci c'est le fait
d'avoir constamment quelque chose à
l'esprit d'ailleurs en français quand on
dit qu'on se soucie de quelque chose ça
ne veut pas forcément dire se faire du
souci ça veut dire la voir à l'esprit
la voir en vue
le souci c'est l'attention portée à ce
qui est en jeu dans notre vie
le bureau ne se soucie pas de ce qui est
en jeu dans sa vie
il ne se projette pas dans son avenir de
bureau
il ne se pose pas de questions
existentielles
nous si alors oui pas tout le temps il y
a des moments où on n'est pas dans le
souci de l'être quand on est avachi sur
le canapé devant une série en train de
végéter on pourrait dire qu'à ce
moment-là aux yeux de Heidegger on n'est
pas vraiment dans l'existence
puisqu'on n'est pas dans l'attention à
ce qui est en jeu dans notre vie c'est
vrai mais le fait est que si la série
capture notre attention ça va se
traduire chez l'individu par de la
projection
par un désir d'anticiper ce qui va
arriver ou de comprendre ce qui est en
jeu
donc même si le sujet ne dirige pas son
souci vers sa propre existence il le
dirige néanmoins vers quelque chose
donc c'est bien la preuve que le souci
est quelque chose de permanent
la meilleure illustration du souci étant
le travail
quand on travaille on a en vue un
résultat
et avoir en vue un résultat c'est faire
une projection temporelle
on parlait tout à l'heure de l'outil et
du fait que l'être de l'outil c'est de
nous servir à accomplir une tâche et
bien l'outil c'est l'enfant du souci
le souci est projection temporelle
projection temporelle d'un résultat et
l'outil c'est l'instrument par lequel on
rejoint ce résultat
qu'est-ce qui est visé quand on utilise
un outil que ce soit pour travailler que
ce soit pour bricoler ou même pour jouer
c'est le résultat
on anticipe le résultat
on anticipe le formulaire rempli avec le
stylo on anticipe l'étagère posé au mur
avec la visseuse
le smash qu'on va envoyer à l'adversaire
avec la raquette
la projection fait de nous des êtres
préoccupés
prêt
occupé
occupé par avance
occupé mentalement avant d'être occupé
physiquement
sans cette préoccupation permanente
l'être humain ne serait pas l'être
humain
et c'est là qu'on peut faire le lien
avec ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure à
propos du monde ambiant le monde ambiant
c'est le monde des outils familiers
c'est le monde dans lequel nous sommes
afférés
affairés en affaires et l'affaire c'est
ce qu'il y a à faire
le tazaï n'a toujours quelque chose à
faire
et qu'est-ce que le design a toujours à
lui-même
et c'est ce qui fait dire à Heidegger
que la première modalité de l'être du
nasaïn ces lettres au monde
l'être au monde c'est le fait d'être
toujours déjà en rapport avec le monde
comme nous qui est en rapport avec
d'autres outils même si l'ignore
l'être au monde quoi de girl distingue
de l'être dans le monde c'est le fait
que l'être humain est un être en rapport
et s'il y a une chose vis-à-vis de quoi
l'être humain est particulièrement en
rapport une chose dont il est conscient
dont il est soucieux et qui est
absolument constitutif de son être c'est
la mort
l'être humain est un être pour la mort
un être en rapport avec sa propre mort
et c'est là dessus qu'on va terminer
notre exposé
idegger nous dit ce n'est pas la même
chose de mourir pour un être humain et
de mourir pour un animal
parce que l'être humain sait qu'il va
mourir
l'animal l'ignore
alors oui l'animal peut avoir conscience
de la mort au sens où face à un danger
il sait qu'il faut fuir
il fuit parce qu'il sent la mort venir
mais ce n'est pas la même chose de
sentir et de savoir
pour l'animal la mort constitue un
accident
un risque lié à un danger
tandis que pour l'homme la mort n'est
pas seulement un accident
c'est une destination finale
c'est ce qui arrivera dans tous les cas
tôt ou tard
pour l'être humain la mort c'est
l'inéluctable
et cette conscience de la mort qui est
celle du design Heidegger en fait la
structure primordiale de son être la
structure primordiale c'est-à-dire que
l'existence humaine est conditionnée par
cette conscience de la mort pourquoi
parce que la conscience de la mort
génère l'angoisse et l'angoisse c'est
cette menace permanente qui sépare
l'existence présente de la mort future
l'existence humaine est une existence en
sursis
l'être humain c'est ce qui doit vivre
avec cette épée Damoclès constamment
au-dessus de sa tête à se demander non
pas s'il va mourir mais quand il va
mourir
où il va mourir
pourquoi il va mourir
est-ce que je vais mourir dans mon
sommeil est-ce que je vais mourir d'une
maladie
d'un accident
est-ce que j'aurai le temps de dire
adieu à mes proches
est-ce que je vais souffrir
c'est terrifiant
c'est terrifiant de ne pas savoir mais
c'est encore plus terrifiant que ce non
savoir
s'intègre dans une certitude totale qui
est la certitude de notre mort à venir
c'est tellement terrifiant que nous
aussi nous faisons comme l'animal face à
un danger
nous fuyons
et toute notre existence quotidienne
n'est qu'une gigantesque fuite
individuelle et collective face à
l'angoisse de la mort
on va fuir l'angoisse de la mort en
l'occultant en la recouvrant
donc on va la recouvrir par d'autres
pensées par des pensées pratiques
dépenser qui vont
occuper notre conscience pour la
détourner pour la divertir
s'occuper c'est se donner la possibilité
de ne pas penser à la mort
mais on va aussi développer une autre
stratégie le travestissement
et c'est là-dessus qu'on est très fort
travestir la mort pour la rendre moins
redoutable
pour l'incorporer à notre quotidienne
et comment est-ce qu'on va s'y prendre
on va faire comme si la mort n'était pas
une expérience personnelle
on va l'universaliser
on va parler de la mort comme quelque
chose qui arrive à tout le monde
et là vous allez me dire bah oui la mort
ça arrive à tout le monde
ou mais sauf qu'en disant ça on fait de
la mort une abstraction
on fait de la mort quelque chose qui ne
nous concerne pas directement
or ce qui nous terrifie dans la mort ce
n’est pas le fait que tout le monde
meurt c'est le fait que je vais mourir
dire on meurt tous un jour c'est fuir la
mort puisque c'est fuir le caractère
intime de notre mort
quand on dit on meurt tous un jour c'est
qui on
ces personnes
ont c'est une manière de ne pas dire je
on c'est une stratégie verbale qui
recouvre une stratégie existentielle qui
est la stratégie de la fuite face à la
mort
on meurt tous un jour non
la réalité c'est que je vais mourir
je vais mourir
la mort des autres ce n'est pas la mort
parce que ce n'est pas ma mort
la mort se vit à la première personne
une mort à la troisième personne ce
n'est pas une mort c'est un décès ça n'a
rien à voir
ça rassure de voir la mort comme quelque
chose d'universel
ça permet d'oublier la mort qui touche
tout le monde
la mort qui parce qu'elle touche tout le
monde ne me touche pas moi
c'est ça la fuite face à la mort
son universalisation
sa conceptualisation
qui nous permet d'éviter sa
confrontation
parce que se confronter à sa propre mort
c'est peut-être pire que mourir
c'est comme jouer à cache-cache avec le
diable
vaut mieux être bien caché
la stratégie par laquelle nous fuyons
l'idée de la mort
Heidegger appelle
l'inauthenticité
l'inauthenticité c'est quand notre
existence est écrasée par le refus de
voir la réalité en face
la vérité du je vais mourir
alors on se réfugie derrière des
abstractions derrière des phrases toutes
faites derrière le on
et on oublie on oublie qu'on va mourir
on oublie que cette mort est
constitutive de notre être et se faisant
on fait comme les philosophes depuis
l'Antiquité
on oublie l'être lui-même
alors on travaille on se divertit on
bavarde
croyant que tant qu'on ne regarde pas la
mort elle n'existe pas
elle n'existe pas pour nous
et on espère que bien caché derrière le
on la mort ne nous verra pas
je cite
la question de l'être est aujourd'hui
tombée dans l'oubli notre époque certes
mais à son compte comme un progrès de
tenir à nouveau en faveur la
métaphysique toutefois l'effort la peine
que cela demanderait d'engager une
nouvelle bataille géante sur l'être on
s'en tient pour dispenser la question
que nous touchons là n'est pourtant pas
une question quelconque à la tenue en
haleine Platon et Aristote dans leur
investigation il est vrai aussi qu'elle
s'est tue à partir de là en tant que
question et thème d'une recherche
véritable ce qu'ils ont tous deux
atteint c'est néanmoins conservés à
travers toute une variété de décalage et
de repeint jusque dans la Logique de
Hegel et ce que la pensée a autrefois
enlevé de haute lutte au phénomène
fusent par fragment et dans de premier
pas le voilà depuis longtemps trivialisé
ce n'est pas tout la même ou les Grecs
avaient jeté les bases d'une
interprétation de lettres un dogme c'est
constitué qui non seulement déclare
superflu la question du sens de être
mais de plus légitime qu'elle soit
purement et simplement chômée on dit
l'être et le concept le plus général et
le plus vide comme tel il résiste à tout
essaie de définition ce concept d'être
le plus général est donc indéfinissable
n'a d'ailleurs pas à être défini chacun
en fait constamment usage et entend déjà
aussi ce qu'il veut dire chaque fois par
là ainsi ce dont l'énigme incita les
anciens à philosopher se trouve devenu
pour nous un lieu commun clair comme le
jour à tel point que celui qui
questionne encore en ce sens se voir
reprocher une erreur de méthode qui dit
élaboration de la question de l'être dit
par conséquent qu'un étang celui qui
questionne se rend transparent à
lui-même en son être dès lors que poser
cette question est un mode d'être d'un
étang le questionnement qu'à l'instant
doit lui-même l'essentiel de sa
détermination au questionner qui est
visé en lui à l'être cette étant que
nous sommes chaque fois nous-mêmes et
qui a entre autres possibilités d'être
celle de questionner nous lui faisons
place dans notre terminologie sous le
nom de dasaïn lettre même par rapport
auquel le dasaïn peut se comporter de
tel ou telle manière et vis-à-vis duquel
il a toujours une certaine attitude nous
le nommons existence et comme la
détermination de cet étang dans son
essence ne peut s'accomplir en donnant
de lui une définition qui exprimerait sa
réalité comme son essence repose bien
plus tôt en ce qu'il a chaque fois à
être son être en tant que celui-ci n'est
qu'à lui c'est le terme d'asagne pure
expression d'être qui est choisi comme
marque distinctive de cet étang le dasaï
s'entend soi-même toujours à partir de
son existence une possibilité de
soi-même possibilité d'être soi-même ou
de ne pas l'être c'est possible ou bien
le design les a choisi même ou bien il y
est tombé ou bien il a chaque fois déjà
grandi en elle se prendre en main ou
négliger de le faire ces manières
d'exister il appartient chaque fois au
d'asagne et à lui seul dans décider la
mort est une possibilité d'être que le
design a chaque fois a assumé lui-même
avec la mort le Dazaï a rendez-vous avec
lui-même dans son pouvoir être le plus
propre dans cette possibilité là il y va
purement et simplement pour le design de
son être au monde sa mort et la
possibilité de ne plus être design si le
dasagne est imminent à lui-même sous la
forme de cette possibilité de soi il est
complètement renvoyé à son pouvoir être
le plus propre le tazaï n’est pas en
mesure de dépasser la possibilité de la
mort la mort et la possibilité de la
purée simple impossibilité du dazine
aussi la mort se révèle-t-elle comme la
possibilité la plus propre sans relation
au design d'autrui un dépassable
pour heiliger
exister authentiquement
ce n'est pas fuir l'idée de la mort
la fronter non seulement comme quelque
chose d'inéluctable mais surtout
l'affronter comme quelque chose qui ne
s'oppose pas à l'existence
mais qui la constitue
la mort ne met pas simplement un terme à
l'existence
elle lui donne du sens
le sens de l'existence c'est de passer
de la fuite à l'affrontement
du déni à la vérité
de l'inauthenticité à l'authenticité
et c'est en ce sens que la mort est une
occasion
c'est précisément parce qu'on sait qu'un
jour tout ça disparaîtra
que nous vivrons notre fin du monde
personnel
qu'il nous est possible de découvrir
notre véritable soi
de nous libérer du faux du mensonge de
la fuite
de tout ce qui rend notre existence
factice
affronter l'idée de la mort c'est
embrasser l'être véritable
c'est lui donner une chance
car de la même façon que vous serez seul
face à votre mort
vous êtes seul à choisir ce que doit
être votre existence
je vous remercie
[Musique]